- [Gary] It breaks my heart my
friends live for Friday night.
Monday morning's the worst.
It's just a huge
percentage of one's life.
I can't wrap my head
around with the internet.
This is not your
grandpappy's life.
We have the internet,
you can make shit happen.
You can build businesses
or side hustles,
I just don't understand why
people relegate into
losing mentality and
just thinking they can't.
You can't because you want
to be on the bowling team
or softball or play video games,
that's why you can't.
There's plenty of time,
get shit done.
The level of complaining
is unacceptable.
Look, what if I told you
this was the last
Monday morning of your life?
What if I told you
you die this week?
Would you complain
about your crap job
or that test you
don't want to take?
I doubt it.
You would go much
higher level thinking.
Well, that's really
what it takes.
It takes understanding that if
you're not pumped right now,
if you're begrudging
what you're about to do,
if you're not looking forward,
please recognize the
world we're living in.
We're living in a world where
there's so much more opportunity.
This internet thing created way
more opportunity for all of us.
Way more. I mean, look,
you may not even be alive.
Your mom and dad coulda
had sex like three minutes later
and you wouldn't even exist
and you're complaining.
You coulda ended up being a bus,
a tree. I just don't get the
mentality of being head down,
sad on a Monday morning.
I'm gonna make Monday
morning my bitch.
I'm going to make you
Saturday, Monday morning.
That's what I want
to do every morning
and that's what I want from you.
Please, take a step back
and think about how
awesome it actually is
and then recognize that
you can attack the world
in a totally different way
'cause you were lucky enough
to be born during this era.
(light music)